well hello there youtubers welcome to
another PI game tutorial video in this
video what we're doing is extending our
button function right now obviously
we've got our beautiful hover action
going on it feels looks and feels like a
button but doesn't quite act like a
button so um we already know that there
is a way to know where the mouse is
because that's how we're actually making
the buttons look interactive but how do
we know when the buttons been clicked um
because it's not a button so how do we
like have event handling for something
that's not a button well it just so
turns out that there are ways to do this
so let's go up to a button function and
what I'll go ahead and do is the
following
so we've got a definition of Mouse we
also can have a definition of a click so
we just say click equals pie game dot
Mouse get under score not position but
pressed it just so happens that PI game
collects all kinds of data all the time
and on your mouse it collects the left
right and middle button uh so let's go
ahead and save and run that really quick
and we'll just come over here I'll just
put this here and I'll move this over
here
nice beautiful annals click oh we didn't
print any click nice what a fool
uh so print click under run that at one
more time and uh now as you can see it's
a constant stream and uh as we click you
can see the ones appeared and I'm
holding down my left button cool holding
down my right now we've got a bunch of
ones and then my Center got a bunch of
ones now this is not including the mouse
wheel rolling its clicking the mouse
wheel for the center just for clarity
but we're mostly interested in the left
click well since we have we're getting
the mouse position how do we know when
there's been a click well when mouse
position element 0 is a
one we've got to click so let's close
out of this and now we can ask the
question first of all we're only curious
about a click whenever we're within the
bounds of our button right so we can
come right here and we can say if click
0 equals 1 what do we want to do prints
nuclear missiles launched okay
so we'll save and run that and now we've
got this I'll print out all that
nastiness that's okay we'll just keep
that printing out trying to arrange it
but when we click on our screen now
we'll click on the go and we can see
it's spamming out all the nuclear
missiles that we've launched so it does
know when we're clicking on our or about
it so if we know when we're clicking on
that button adding functionality that's
only one step away now so what we can do
is we can do something like we can come
over to our game intro and our button
here and we can add another parameter
and this parameter is oops
in quotes here play and this parameter
is quit easy enough so then what we can
do is we can come up to our actual
button function we need to add one more
thing to it and we're just going to add
action and that's two parameters and
then we can come down here to art this
if statement and then we're asking if
click zero equals one and then actually
we can well let's make action the
parameter have a default of none so we
can say action equals none that's in the
parameters so we can ask if click zero
is one
and action exclamation mark equals as in
not equal uh none now we want to do
something and then what we can do is we
can say if action let's see yeah if
action equals play what do we want to do
well now we just want to run the game
loop right so we just run this function
right here so I'll copy that then we'll
come back up here and we will do game
loop params then we can also ask L if
action equals quit what do we want to do
well we just run a PI game dot quit
uninitialized PI game and then quit now
we should have functionality in our
button so let's go ahead and save or run
that and we hit go and now we're playing
our game like a bunch of ballers and we
crash um nice and you crash ok and then
uh what we can do is let's do it again
and then we can hit quit and that quits
the game for us
so like I was saying in the last video
though this isn't quite the best because
one only want to have like a button
function that performs any function that
we pass through because this is kind of
sloppy I mean I'm gonna be honest this
isn't the best way to do it um so the
question is can we pass a function
through you can't pass a whole function
through because if you do something like
that like action equals none um just for
kicks you don't have to yeah you can
follow along if you'd like um but let's
say um here's a tip as well for you guys
if you want to comment out a block you
can use the multi-line comment or you
can use a shorthand commenting where you
highlight this block of code alt 3 and
now you've commented out this code it's
very fast I love doing it so if you
didn't know that congratulations I
didn't know that for at least two years
and I'm so thankful to have found it now
and just so you know if you want
comment that alt for so keep that in
mind anyway so what would be ideal is
that we just say if there is in action
it's not none let's let's just do that
action right that'd be great
so we would come down here and we would
say uh let's go to our game intro here
our action instead of being play is
actually let's run quit quits a little
more makes a lot more sense so quit
right actually quit needs two things so
let's let's do play I'm sorry guys
so so let's just straight up pass game
loop through here but here's the problem
when we go to when we go to load code if
you throw a function in there it's going
to run so when we save or run this it's
gonna wait for a while and it's gonna
show us straight into the game now uh
what might we be able to do well we
could go something like this game loop
and then game loop immediately runs like
you could try to cheat the system right
so you could say uh game intro like a so
um but the problem here okay uh we get
it a bit of an infinite loop but anyways
um I thought it would be more
interesting than a bunch of red text but
anyway um so he can't click we can't do
that but you might ask well what if we
pass the object right the the actual
function object so we just delete the uh
parenthesize so save and run that and we
click go nothing happens because now all
we're doing is referencing the object
what if then we come up here and we add
the function thingies to action and now
we can get through and actually do the
action but then the next question
remains
what about actions like the quit
functionality that we want
well our quit actually wants to be two
things so we could kind of cheat and do
this very sloppy and instead of quit we
could just do quit and really just mess
up the whole whole thing um okay oops
yeah I just quit nope no parameters
that's how we do it and then you get
quit um see it's not going to want to
quit because we are on OS Lee okay so it
let's run that let me run that real
quick of I uh sorry I think I'm having
too much fun with this actually what
freakin tutorial number are we on 15
that would be this one here
game video 15 run it this might actually
work but we're never uninitialized my
game yeah so that worked but we're not
on initializing PI game so that's not
the ideal result so then what you would
need to do is if event dot type equals
PI game quit we need to just have like a
you know exit game functionality
something like that um because I don't
think that we can get away with you know
maybe we could add if quit or something
I don't know anyway there's always the
all kinds of stuff that you can do
because for the most part when you click
a button you really just want one
function to run you're not actually
trying to run multiple functions here um
in fact maybe what we could do is run a
PI game that quit game loop we could run
uh no there's no way to get away from
this anyway whatever um so you know you
might have to define a quick look define
a quit game function and then have that
be like hi game quit and then
it and then you pass quit game through
instead of quit like that
save and run it and now our NGO works
fabulous and the quit works or should
work I'm already saying it works but I'm
just assuming that it's gonna work
I make no mistakes uh-huh so anyway uh
that's how we can pass actions through
our buttons and have our buttons be
pretty functional so at this point you
can actually just you can use this
button function it's not even that long
of a function really I'm gonna get rid
of this stuff so don't need it anymore
um and and and that's all you needed so
why this is not included in um pygame
naturally I don't know but um you know
if you just gave in active color and
active color a default color option
maybe that's why I don't know because
then because nobody predefined colors
either there really should be predefined
colors and pygame
too I'm not like quite sure why there's
not like predefined it leaves like white
black red green blue like that just
makes total sense to me why wouldn't you
predefined I have those like it built
into PI game but whatever so anyway I'm
just not really sure why buttons aren't
built into PI game either they've got a
lot of really really great functionality
and PI games so it is kind of weird that
you'd off buttons built in and I have
seen like some third-party button
modules but they're a lot more complex
than this I'm not quite sure why you
need anything more complex than this
maybe kind of cool to have like rounded
edges to your buttons I challenge anyone
to do that one good luck if you want to
do that so anyway um that's going to be
it for now
I have some high hopes for some like PI
game games that I want to make not
really sure when I'll release the next
batch of Pi game videos but hopefully
this will tide you guys over for your PI
game fix for now if you guys have any
questions or comments feel free to leave
them below if you have any requests or
like there's
things very specific you want to see
like how can we do X in PI game please
do not ask me to like do you know crazy
stuff in PI game I'm not going to make
battlefield 4 and PI game but if you
guys have something that you really want
to see how it's done in PI game or like
maybe how might you do something cause
like buttons for example there's no way
like immediately built into PI game to
make buttons but you can use tools and
make buttons anyways so anyways if you
guys have any requests feel free to make
them as always thank you for watching
things for all the support and
subscriptions in until next time